[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're taking
a look at how to make
some scars bruises and
bleeding cuts with some DIY makeup.
Some of which is made
from stuff you probably already have.
[Music]
Guys, we have Calli back
here in the studio,
and she's going to be helping
us out with something fun today.
Calli, what is it
we're going to be doing?
>> Well.
I'm going to beat you up.
>> Aww.
>> Well, I'm gonna do it
in a nice way.
We've got some DIY Halloween
makeup styles that we're going
to be doing.
Bruises, blood, cuts,
it's going to be interesting.
But with some household
supplies that you can find
pretty darn easy,
all the way up
to some things
that you might find
at the local theater store
or even Walmart.
>> All right, so what are
these supplies were looking at?
Some of these I think
I recognize and some of them,
I also recognize,
but that's because I've done
some theater makeup before.
So, just walk us
through a little bit of what
we've got here on the table.
>> Flour, baby powder, Vaseline,
pretty darn simple.
With these supplies, you
can actually make a scar putty.
Now, I do have
theatrical scar wax.
That is something that a lot
of people will use in makeup
and theater,
but you can make it
at home for a lot cheaper.
So, I'm going to show you
how to do that.
Moving up to liquid latex.
Now, not all latex
is made the same.
You're going to see
the difference between
our Walmart latex
and some theatrical supply makeup.
I'm going to show you how
you can basically make
it look the same,
work the same for you.
And then liquid collodion,
which... it's probably more fun
to just show you what that does.
>> So, here's the plan, Calli is going
to take some of our makeup supplies,
and she's going to start
applying them to me,
and explaining how to do it,
to make it look like I suffered
some grievous injury.
Like, maybe someone
hit me in the face,
with a big old weapon.
>> The basic idea when
you're doing makeup like this,
sometimes less is more.
You kind of want to focus
on the bone structure
and you also want to focus
on where the skin's really
going to split.
So if Nate were to get hit
say right there,
he probably end up
with a black eye,
some swelling around the eye,
and then a pretty good slice in his face.
So, let's see
if we can make that look real.
So the first step is we're going
to take some flour,
and we're going to take some Vaseline,
we're going to mix them together.
We're going to tone it,
to attempt to match your skin.
And then we're going
to add it on.
We'll probably add
a little bit of spirit gum.
Also something that you can find
at your local Walmart,
grocery store,
Theatrical supply store,
so that it's going to stick
a little bit better,
and then we're going to add
some color and some blood.
>> Let's get this party started.
We don't actually
need this much but,
just you can kind of
see what I'm doing.
>> Vaseline petroleum jelly.
>> Straight Vaseline, yup.
>> Normal [inaudible], brand
doesn't matter but--
>> Really doesn't,
I just got the regular brand,
just picked it up from Walmart.
I have experimented using
baby powder as well,
works pretty darn good
but the absorbency
is a little bit different,
so we're going to stick
with the flour,
which is what a lot of people use,
and it's going to make
the tinting a little bit easier
and a little bit more opaque,
which in this case is actually
going to be a good thing when
we're applying color over it.
Usually you're going to want
a little bit thinner,
but this should be fine.
So, what we're looking
for is basically
a paste-like consistency,
almost a Play-Doh.
It's actually going
to be very similar
to when you Proto-putty.
>> This point, I would say
that we have approximately
twice as much flour,
as we do Vaseline by volume.
>> So if you touch it,
does it stick to your skin?
Nope, not really.
Okay, good.
So right now,
we've got pretty much,
the perfect consistency.
So that's what
we're looking for.
So now, here's the fun part.
I had to make up match Nate.
>> So, if you go
to the makeup store
because you want to make this,
you ask one of the nice people
working there where you can find,
liquid foundation
in your skin color.
And, they'll be very helpful,
and they'll show you where to go.
>> In case you wondered
what color Nate skin is,
it's basically primer white.
It's classic Ivory.
You're about as pale
as you can possibly be.
>> That hurts my feelings a little
bit, but it's very true.
This stuff is not like,
super runny thin.
It's kind of like,
ketchup consistency.
And that's also good.
>> And now I mix this up
the same way, right?
>> Yes.
So, this consistency now,
I would say, sugar cookie dough.
Yeah.
That's a good description.
Don't eat it though.
Don't--
No, you eat most things,
don't eat this.
>> Oh-- Mmm.
Mmm-mmm
Is it working?
I can feel it tingling
on my gum.
They're so stale.
>> Put it down.
All right, so when it comes
to doing the sort of makeup,
you don't have to break the bank.
That's why we're kind of
doing this all DIY style.
So you'll actually
recognize some of this stuff.
If you've ever been
to a Halloween store
or even Walmart,
these are just some really
simple grease paints.
And if you apply them right,
you're going to get some pretty
darn cool colors.
So I'm sure
that Nate skin is very clean,
but just in case to make sure
that everything applies
properly, we're going to use
some witch Hazel astringent.
It's just a little bit gentler
than some others.
>> As an astringent,
it means it's going
to strip oils off of my face,
and we don't want
that long-term or forever,
but it makes it so that all
of the makeup can stick
to my skin a lot better.
>> Once the skin is clean
you want to add a layer
of spirit gum.
Now, this is going to help
that putty stay
a little bit better,
especially because it is
a DIY mixture that we've made.
>> Spirit gum is like,
skin glue made
out of pine trees, I think.
As she's dabbing this on with her finger,
I can feel it as it dries out.
It starts getting stickier
and sticker.
You can probably see how it
was getting more and more stuck
to her finger
as she lightly
tapped it in place.
>> So, what I'm looking for is
a really really thin layer.
You can kind of see
that we've got this really
shiny, tacky surface.
I want to work quickly
before it dries too much.
But I also don't want
it to be so thick
that it gets gummy.
If it gets too thick,
it's going to start pulling
away from the skin, and then
not only is your prosthetic
not going to stick,
but you could potentially
hurt your... patient?
>> Victim?
>> Victim.
So, to apply this makeup,
it's not going to be very difficult.
You don't really
need anything very fancy.
I'm really just starting out
with a cut popsicle stick.
Make sure the ends aren't sharp.
Again, we're really
not trying to injure him,
just make it look
like I injured him.
I really don't want to get
in trouble for hurting Nate.
So I went for just more
of a... angled spatula.
The idea is basically
that we want to be able
to smooth down the edges,
make sure it looks pretty
darn seamless between his skin,
and the prosthetic.
So, even with my spirit gum,
the edges are starting
to pull up a little bit
because that flour
is absorbing the Vaseline.
So, we're going to take a Q-tip
and we're going
to add a little bit
more Vaseline just
around the edges,
just to smooth things out.
Well, I think that's at
least going to be a pretty
darn good arc for our cut,
so let's add some bruising.
At this point, it just
comes down to color theory.
We want to make sure
that we can match Nate's skin
as closely as possible.
He's got a very pale skin,
but a pink undertone.
[Music]
So here's the fun part,
doesn't have to be expensive.
You don't have to use
anything super crazy.
So this was $3 at Walmart,
this was I think $2,
and that's really all you need.
So we're going to take,
our $2 brushes, and let's start
with some black
and purple.
Make sure that you
also use some skin tones,
but really just
mix and match
until you get what you want.
So this is basically
just the same
as those little grease pencils.
It's just even softer.
So one of the important parts
when you're working on this
again, just take your time,
be patient,
and don't use one color.
When you use one of those colors
on these really bright,
you know, color palettes,
you saw that I was working
with a bright red
and a bright purple.
But when you start
blending them,
that's when you get it
to look really realistic,
even with the really, really cheap makeup.
This palette is probably $7,
so out of all of our makeup
today probably one
of the more expensive ones.
But, it lasts me for years
and I can use it for stuff
like this all the time.
I'm going to be honest,
I've only ever done this
to myself once,
usually I'm putting makeup
on other people.
What does that feel like?
>> It's barely noticeable,
honestly.
Unless I start moving
my face around,
then I can sort of feel
it being tight in spots.
Like where the spirit gum
and where the prosthetic putty,
is sort of like,
resisting where
my skin would normally move--
>> But it's not uncomfortable?
>> No, not at all like, it's less of a feel.
Like, if I had just
a bandaid on my face,
I think I would feel that more,
than I feel this.
>> So when you're doing makeup like this,
you'll notice that I'm not putting nearly
as much red on the prosthetic,
as I am around the eye.
When your skin swells up
in an actual cut or injury,
you're going to have
less blood to that area.
Now there is going to be blood
in the wound of course,
but the redness
is actually going
to be swelling around it,
and not necessarily right
on top of the area.
[Music]
How you feeling, Nate?
>> I got beat up.
>> Yeah.
So, we've got
a pretty good shiner.
We've got his face,
pretty darn puffy.
You can still see the Vaseline,
and the, flour coming through a little bit.
So what we're going to do now,
is we're actually going to slice
his cheek open,
and add some blood.
You're going to see
that it's just going
to pull that wax right off.
So, to keep it from doing that,
we're going to add some Vaseline.
Hold still while I
cut your face open.
[Music]
That cut's going really jagged,
that's actually going to look kind of cool.
Now this, was just
a happy accident.
When Nate smiles-- Nate, smile.
You get this little crinkle
right here.
So I'm actually going to use
that, into the split itself.
Just sort of, add on
to the horror factor.
Now, all I'm going to do is...
add in a little bit of reddening,
and then we're going to set it,
because right now it's very shiny.
You can tell that there's
Vaseline or something there.
So we're going to dull
it down, make it match
the matte of Nate's skin,
and then we're going, to finish
with adding some blood.
Are there other ways to do this?
Yes.
Is this more entertaining?
Also, yes.
>> That smells terrible.
>> There are lots of ways
that you can actually
make homemade blood but
because we've already
made our homemade putty,
we're going to go
and use some from
the theatrical supply store.
You can also get this at Walmart
and at any Halloween shop that
you want to find.
Make it look most realistic.
Let gravity do its work.
I'm barely tapping it in there,
and I'm going to let it just sort of
fall, the way it naturally would.
Now, let's go out in public.
>> I got beat up by a girl.
>> All right.
Well, we've successfully,
beat the crud out of Nate.
Sorry Nate,
but I haven't
gotten to use the latex
or the liquid collodion yet.
Hey Mark, come here.
[Music]
So, what you guys
do at work today?
>> Messed up, pretty bad.
>> Got beat up by a girl.
Yup.
>> All right, you have successfully
blackened my eye,
and bloodied up my face...
But at this time, we want to see
how hard is it to take this off.
Like, if I were doing this
for my Halloween makeup,
going to a party
something like that.
I get done at the end
of the night.
Is it going to take me
forever to clean my face up?
>> No, that's kind
of the best part
about this sort of makeup.
So, this is just Wish Hazel.
It's an astringent,
wipe it right off.
>> Mmm.
>> Gross.
>> Just wiping off part
of my skin here.
So I had that on, for probably
two or maybe three hours,
and it was staying on just fine.
Like, it worked pretty well.
I think you could
easily have that on
for an evening for a party,
something like that.
>> But honestly, if you just
take some makeup wipes to it,
it's not going
to hurt your skin.
The worst thing
is the spirit gum,
and that will come off
in the shower,
if you really need it to.
So...
>> I think even most
of that's gone.
Thank you to Calli for sharing
her knowledge with us.
I hope some of you have
some fun makeup that you
want to try for Halloween.
If you do, tag us
on social media #TKOR,
#TheKingofRandom, one of those.
We want to check it out.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
We've got more
for you to see.
That box of the top
will take you directly
to our last video.
You should go
check that one out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribe to our Channel,
and that way you'll never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.